Oh Oh Lord gang go Oh Oh floor gang no
gag oh oh oh
welcome back smash like for floor gang
if you're stealing gang get that flip
out of here go god I'm so comfortable
how far do you think again stretch them
do you dude childbirth must be like so
easy what's the problem girls huh got
cramp I gotta sit like this welcome to
the why there you go Felix fixed it for
you nice
you know rhettandlink has been calling
me harassing me the entire weekend
delete the evidence delete the evidence
no one can know Felix well the evidence
is out we just need a computer-generated
version and they're done for amazing
absolutely amazing you know they don't
even make jeans these types we I gotta
get them special mate it's a problem
just the normal minecraft or keep
scrolling okay I guess I keep scroll all
right I'll watch see what this is all
about fine fine I'll wait to see what
it's going to be alright so pretty cool
it's a cold decent stuff I'll give it
I'll give it to you
could it be flora gang we'll see all
right that's just wow that's a lot of
diamond that's incredible
oh no oh there's diamond blow up action
honor all to just go back home how about
that that's amazing oh my god said you
know I think we need to tone it back on
the ship it's like this word means
something
new to everyone on the goddamn planet at
this point not everything is a sip don't
ruin the word you understand that we
finally have something powerful to
strike back at all the guys that suck up
to women
all right I'm not sucking up to women
look childbirth easy I'll be the first
one to say it but baby got out what's
problem oh damn my crap I don't even
feel the cramps oh god I don't feel
anything
oh I gotta sit like this now floor gang
is the best I love it
four-year-old me pretending to be a
submarine in the public swimming we've
all done this smash like if he will so
done this let's flow a gang right there
how am I gonna say I don't swedish
millionaire can't get a table there they
don't deliver them anymore I know I get
it it's tough for everyone right now but
it's especially tough for me okay I'm
suffering casually watching pizza got a
lot of videos oh yeah oh yeah I told him
I was good what what's the problem honey
enough what's up
just hold left leg oh my god oh my god
[Music]
okay damn I think I think I actually
read comments telling them about this
but in like the first episodes I've done
thank you you saved me a couple seconds
in minecraft this is invaluable
you're definitely floor again floor gang
and big peepee I'll say it when your
wife's boyfriend lets you stay up past
bedtime and plate thanks thanks Chad
Pierce has no legs so this must be
I'll let the imagination do the rap
I'm telling you big pp is floor gang how
can I be more yeah this is good
cool story bro I became vegan because I
watched couch getting butchered in VR
that's awful
I understand oh sorry I was covering the
screen people wondering why I'm not
playing subnautica because I'm
uncomfortable I can't sit like this I
mean I'm extremely comfortable floor
gang best motivation to stay at home
stay at home or dance with us I mean
that's what you're making it seem like a
win-win to be honest the full truth
there it is another evidence revealed at
last there will be justice Atlanta
I bet written link our ceiling gang
crash goddamn that's amazing that's
definitely floor gang big PP right there
gotta buy an egg a that's so cute dude
we need we need Jojo pewdiepie edition
real reason might say I leave you don't
mean my wife
I mean to be fair I could do it mom
whenever we're sometimes I record when
we travel and I'm always so subconscious
about neighbors and I was asking I like
wasn't I extremely large do I know
I guess she's so conditioned to it
that's what it is instant puberty when
food said you are no longer 9 year old
now your 19 year old man your own ideal
19 yo
Bosko your welcome gamers you're welcome
that's floor game there it is oh my god
dude that's sick I want it I want it I
need it I love the purple string -
that's dope
is there an aperture science reference
very nice Felix was way ahead oh that's
right flora gang I've been floor again
since 2016 I've been prepared for what
was about to come I knew the prophecy I
can see everything from down here I
don't know who or what Joe Jewish and at
this point I'm too afraid too I know
it's yo yo yo yo you know you my last
pouch got removed but the word must get
out yeah I saw ton of comments about
this I feel bad Brendan good - I'm sorry
- bad kids are vegan they use cornstarch
- as a bonding agent which is great but
that was my point that every candy ever
uses gelatin and it's like why you can
just use something else so props to you
that's nice and good on Brandon I can't
believe that's not vegan
those aren't vegan they are shut up shut
shut that to me just proves that she
just wanted to please everyone I'm a
blue-eyes White Dragon Oh
oh my god I got so much flak for saying
that you can have four cards in the
yugioh deck I'm sorry it was a while
since I played I played magic in between
I'm sorry
I've never seen people so upset over
anything I said that was wrong God
a lot of Fator from this episode I love
it dude that shirt is low-key fire very
nice this is great big peepee big flora
gang I'm all about it I'm all about it
when it's bedtime but your wife
boyfriend gives you five more minutes
thank you so much Ricardo he's so
generous that's why I'm on floor gang he
just like dude do you want to be on
floor that's it's epic I'm like can I
really
oh my god thank you so much in here I am
on top of the world at the bottom there
there's more
I can't believe brand the cutting South
fan art he's got his buck wait those
aren't beggin this fan art is not vegan
but it is floor again absolutely floored
egg first man who broke his IKEA table
be like up down Lord gang we floor gang
now fellas come on it's awesome
trust me I love it I love sitting here
that's great oh you're vegan name all
the documentaries that inspired you I'll
wait all of them oh you're vegan name
your favorite soap baby soap right now
or bang bang bang bang baby soap tell me
your favorite soap good you may pass
that's vegan you may pass go on I took a
picture of my first year old cousin at
the dinner table oh that's so nice yeah
this was said Ricardo lets me paint on
table and eat chicken nuggets I love it
they are vegan don't worry guys me can
we have M&M marzia we already have M&M
at home
oh let me tubby doesn't let me touch
with the hula do we need a full version
party in the backyard please I'll record
you some lines virgin versus Chad dude
he looks more chat on the left
dude look at that chin what happened why
is so small huh Lennis what happened
look he became tinier
what is this petition for side to make
this intro on the next Lavoie
No all right all right how about this
all right if I make it stop if I make it
stop I'll watch Phineas and Ferb for a
video if this video gets a billion likes
I'll do it okay something feasible a
million likes okay fine
me after I tell my mom a joke a lecture
where's this from that's great nice very
nice
big P P men are always quiet beat by
screaming for five minutes that's not
true we don't always agree he doesn't
even have nether right yeah good good
beeping good beep no you can't just play
around in game you have to read theta
pads so you understand the story haha
fish go blah blah ha ha have to read the
data part okay I'll read them Jesus
Christ dude how good can this story be
it's a video game the four horsemen of
being annoying freaks both my god so
many from the e relates insane they
always fight one super annoying person
at least one go play with the neighbor's
kid the neighbors I'm not the neighbor's
kid
I keep seeing people say I'm the
neighbor skin.this cuz I broke someone's
yo-yo and didn't pay for it doesn't make
me the neighbors kid okay
Oh see you Bri they're not vegan that's
not vegan you kill oxygen molecules
what's wrong with you have some decency
have some thought when you're about to
lose an oh no game then your job that's
right
nice nice mean big PP the wheels on
chappy card be like but he's small but
he's small make no sense
oh my god dude so much great fan art
this week well done bro SHhhh that's
awesome and also a hundred percent
accurate I was doing really to be honest
I was think that's this floor again guys
you wouldn't understand
oh my god I can't show this because it's
copper at music but I'll link to it in
the description give this fire Oh God
alright here we go
cat damn I can do that just give me just
give me another session with my yo-yo
master I mean that's impressive
to be fair next time do it to push
lasagna and do it right small people
probably ceiling gang doctor what
happened to you grandpa I lost that card
game doctor what then why are you dying
it's just a game
grandpa the phrase it's just a game it's
such a weak mindset you are okay with
what happened losing imperfection of a
craft when you stop dying after losing
you've lost there's always something to
learn and there's always room for
improvement never settle
yoky one yogi one I'm glad you guys
enjoyed I got a lot of good feedback on
the last episodes I like it because it's
just me talking about stuff I like I
feel like a lot of times on the internet
with people making content is always
drama and topical stuff so it's fun to
just do your own thing every once in a
while if people is a person yeah yeah
this reminds me of the post here about a
beekeeper actually explaining no we
don't do this things that people say on
their website we do and I saw a lot of
comments from beekeepers shout out to
all the beekeepers watching apparently
there's a ton of you my neighbors I
should be keepers now I think about it
but just how inaccurate what they
described on the website was so maybe I
care about this after all about that you
changed my mind
friends you can't read what you do
looking for memes me you must grow tired
of being wrong all the time well done
well done are we not gonna talk about
how boots suddenly just has hair what
what how it grow it grow out overnight
so I cut it every day and I just forgot
one day basically I'm sorry guys when
you're watching the new Levi's episode
and you see that one meme that you
scroll by a new I like this new meme
template it's funny oh my I really want
a computer-generated one like a really
real
that's all I want that's great
see I'm flora gang I've always been
flora gang haters say I could never be
flora gang but look at me
I've always been always hoots join
YouTube on April 29 2010 so on April 29
2020 will be his 10-year anniversary
YouTube
Duke epic celebration I'm happy you guys
notice thank you that's nice
well done very good when you see Felix
and you want to ask to take selfie but
then you remember he made spend it's
fair fair that's absolutely Aaron when
she realized that what there isn't vegan
because it's official Aaron that's not
vegan anything Jojo related pity pie
I've seen enough I'm satisfied great
dude that jacket imagine that being a
reversible jacket so it's black on the
inside and has this pattern on the
inside that beats freaking dope dude
people are donating money to Kylie
Jenner to help her become the world's
youngest female billionaire dude that is
actually simply right there my god you
know listen anything woman can do I can
do look at this what else what else is
there boobs you want boobs I just need
to drink more soy they'll come naturally
just wait guys the study guide what's
your favorite I love that question so
much it's so funny when you meet your
future husband for the first time and he
pulls out this yo-yo says sappy and sir
I've been phrase that's flora gang
that's how you get the girl no legs how
tall is yogi he's like half the length
of every I'm slow gang to hide my
strength do you hide my power level
everyone knows you need to be activated
at ten percent of all time in case of
furious enemy battle that happened okay
Felix to ride Strider you have to make a
warp fungus on the stick oh my god thank
you that's actually helped
I was wondering you better not be lying
oh my god that's amazing
another shot in making this an actual
thing VP VP I like that come on
mods make it I don't pay you to do sit
around and do nothing because I don't
pay you
[Music]
it happens to the best of us gamers
doesn't get it oh my god someone did it
whoa what leaked footage oh my god
that's insanely accurate with the
movement so yes I mask it as well damn
nice that's insane
let's give a shout out to all my CGI
animators for all the hard work they do
Felix sure to give us another
green-screen competition cuz we board s
nah if you guys stop posting this then
yes we got a deal floor again good life
oh my god so cute I'm a GP oh I'm always
perfect I'm always comfortable that's
the floor gang life oh my god delay
my awesome fiance surprised me with
appeared Steve's birthday he has a very
big peepee fiancee has huge peepee well
done happy birthday gamer that's so
sweet oh happy birthday miss Patrick
very nice haha
there's too many crossovers to not be
real in my head vegans just go for a
more natural that's it for this week's
love why thank you for all the memes
appreciate it remember to keep flooring
and I see you gamers tomorrow yeah Hado
subscribe and stuff you know what's big
peepees do they play beauty
Paes pixel ings of course pixel ings is
a creature collecting game I'm the
primary shareholder over a bazillion
players have downloaded and it's got a
perfect score it's safe to say it's the
most popular game of all time
55 pixel aims it's awesome deal with it
deal with it
[Music]